so are you managing  girls like only fans accounts yeah  well not like running their account but  we're like in charge of promoting them  he's [ __ ] them and then putting them  out there what do you what's your  percentage uh undisclosed nice yeah 75  yo this guy's  if you're a 75 what does only fans keep  like what is it they keep 20 percent of  the night yeah so they keep whatever  they keep 20 and then you get your your  cut and then the girls stuck with the  pennies uh i wouldn't say that i'm just  [ __ ] with you we're making these  ladies rich yeah no so like uh i think  the first i think i ain't gonna say her  name but the first girl within a week  she made what 60 grand a month after  that one more time way more that was  like the first couple days or something  now  yeah because sky bree  scott yeah yeah yeah who are you  managing are you managing that asian  girl that's always on your [ __ ] what's  your name oh me no no she's the witch